des centaines de milliers de petits
enfants ont été sauvés cette année dans
les pays les plus défavorisés grâce à
des méthodes simples et peu coûteuses
cette bonne nouvelle c'est l'unicef le
fonds des nations unies pour l'enfance
qui nous l'apprend dans son rapport
annuel publié hier
de simple sachet de sel et de sucre
comme celui-ci suffisent à réhydrater
des enfants menacés de mort c'est le cas
au bangladesh comme nous l'expliquent
martin alarie niaux plus besoin de
perfusions coûteuse un peu de sel de
sucre et d'eau propre donné à la
cuillère suffisent c'est sans doute le
moins spectaculaire mais le plus grand
progrès médical du siècle un procédé
simple qui permet de réhydrater à la
maison sans aucun personnel médical des
enfants condamnée à mort par des
diarrhées persistantes n'importe quelle
petite industrie locale peut préparer le
mélange sous forme de sachets
préemballés vendus à des prix
accessibles aux pays pauvres mais on
peut aussi encore beaucoup plus
simplement apprendre le faire soi même
en ajoutant les ingrédients aux céréales
ou à la soupe de légumes
partout ce programme élémentaire a été
mis en place avec l'aide de l'unicef
près de 100% de bons résultats ont été
obtenus au bangladesh où la
réhydratation par voie orale et
maintenant couramment employé la
mortalité infantile a baissé de moitié
évidemment pour que cette technique soit
efficace il faut que le gouvernement les
personnels médicaux paramédicaux et tous
ceux qui jouissent d'un précisant le
pays soit motivé mais il faut avant tout
que les familles apprenne à l'utiliser
correctement
si c'est le cas en quelques heures un
enfant à la dernière extrémité que se
trouvait guérissent au bangladesh des
centaines d'agents ont ainsi enseigné à
plus de deux millions et demi de femmes
comment préparer chez elle une version
locale de cette thérapeutique des plus
simples mais qui exige de l'eau propre
ou bouilli en 1986 près de 6 millions de
mères auront été touché par le programme
dans ce pays
trente huit autres pays pauvres
commencent à utiliser le procédé est au
cours de l'année passée
cinq cent mille enfants ont été sauvés
par ce traitement mais c'est bien sûr
encore trop peu l'unicef ne compte pas
en rester là elle a le projet ambitieux
de faire bénéficier dans les cinq années
qui viennent la moitié des enfants du
monde de la réhydratation par voie orale
ce qui signifie sauver 2 millions de
vies d'enfants par an